Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I am just checking in on you.
I'm not yelling at,
I'm in Houston right now and I have a,
I got a show here in a couple
of hours and you know, Bill is,
I am in an advanced age at this point.
You know,
this is how old I am.
I now qualify for something
I never heard of before.
It's called a I p. A. R. P.
I don't know what it does.
It's for old guys like me.
We're not 65.
We're 50 and evidently I can now
go to the movie for eight bucks.
I'd probably get a free side of Metamucil,
you know,
maybe a little Ben [inaudible] Ben
gay when I walk out, but I'm site. So,
um, yeah, don't let anybody ever tell
you that getting old fucking sucks. Okay?
Yeah, it does. You body breaks down.
Eventually you take a dirt nap.
Who's getting who?
You know,
you fucking surrounded by loved ones.
As you're laying there,
everybody's bottom lip quivering. Did
you just sit now? Was I a good person,
good person, right. Yeah. That sucks.
But there's a lot of shit that
balances it off. All right.
$8 tickets to movies,
Bam.
Talking Shit to somebody in their
twenties. You know, like you're a Badass,
but you're too old for
them to fuck with you.
So you look tough right in front
of your 50 year old wife bomb.
MMM. I mean, that's pretty much
the extent of it. I haven't really,
I'm new to this being fucking
over the hill here. Uh,
but you know,
yeah.
Getting aware of stupid hat.
Yeah.
Right. One of those fucking old man coats.
I can't fuck. I mean it's, it's okay.
I can't wait, but uh, I'm
going to enjoy it. Um,
anyways, uh, before we get started, I
have a couple of things to promote. Oh,
rough and rowdy brawl. August 5th, uh,
the people over there when nice
enough l pres, Dave Portnoy's,
uh, was nice enough to invite me back
and of course I jumped at the chance.
I had such a great time the last time
when we were in fucking Charlotte.
Um, it's so cool. And I will show up to
these things as long as they have made,
because a, it's a, it's ridiculously fun.
So it's going to be in
Youngstown, Ohio. All right.
Kids come out of the womb swinging.
All right.
When the doctor hits the baby on the ass
in Youngstown, he's wearing headgear.
That's all I'm saying. And a mouthpiece.
Um, all right. But we get it to tough.
All right. Who knows, I don't
know what their deal is there.
I don't know why they're so
tough there. I imagine, you know,
I think each little pool of people,
you know, starts off with a,
with a couple of Adam and Eve's.
Right? And they bang and then whatever,
if they're in the books, then
you get like Seattle, you know,
but if they got hammered and they
beat the shit out of each other, yeah,
you get Youngstown.
I haven't researched any of this,
but I don't know what all I know is,
I'm not looking at anybody in the eye
when I get there, cause I don't, I don't,
I don't need to be clocked by
fucking Kelly Pavlics third cousin.
Um, but anyways, so I,
I got to do a Gig. A,
I'm going to do a gig right before I
get there. I'm going to be in Rochester,
New York.
All right.
I believe home is Steve Gadd
childhood home. I remember he was,
I remember that I used to watch the
instructional DVD that he had a zillion
times up close and he would talk about
how he got his hands together playing in
the Rochester Crusaders.
It was a drum corps. Um,
I know crazy information, but whatever
it's in my head, I got to get it up. Um,
so that will be on August 4th, August
5th, I'll be driving down to Youngstown.
MMM.
For rough and rowdy.
So go to rough and rowdy
brawl.com to get your tickets.
Um, to stream it. Whatever you got to
do, it's going to be fucking awesome.
And I've already seen some
of the highlights so I
should really retweet some of
the, some of the guys, they got
some Pittsburgh, Cleveland guys,
no love lost there with all the Steelers
trophies and a Cleveland's baron shelf.
Cause for some reason they
don't count NFL titles,
which Cleveland one I think in 65,
but you know, as far as franchises go,
that went out to fucking Baltimore,
Baltimore,
Scarface reference. Um, any hoo,
I'm here in a Houston,
Texas. I'm like, God,
I thought it was going to be
fucking brutally hot. I was like,
I was almost ready to
call my agent and be like,
how many fucking years have
you been in this business?
Slash how many years have you been
booking me that you would book a bald,
redheaded male?
Yeah,
that qualifies for Arp in Houston,
Texas in fucking July.
But um,
when we were coming in for Atlanta and
I was looking out the window and I'll,
all the, you know, fields that I saw
were green. So it was like, all right,
maybe they getting some rain, I don't
know. But it's not that bad down here.
The bad thing is, is I forgot
my show shoes. You know,
for those of you not in show business,
you have your shoes that you
walk around in your shoes,
your workout in or whatever. All right.
This is a very first world here, okay?
For those, those of you listening
in lesser countries, okay,
we are so privileged here that we
have shoes for different events.
I need to work out, right? I'm
going to fucking wear these shoes.
I'm going to go, uh, I don't know. Go run
some errands. Oh, I think I'll grab those.
And then you got to put on a show,
a dance like a monkey.
You have these other fucking shows.
Now I know other people in other towns,
you know, uh, countries I should say.
You know, you've got one pair of shoes.
If you're lucky,
right?
You and 18 other people jump on a fucking
moped with 37 boxes and somehow you
don't tip over. You go down the street
making fucking Instagram videos.
I see out there, I see out there all
the time. I don't know how you'd do it.
Is it like young style where
you just grow up fighting?
You guys just grow up fucking stack
and shit up on tea. It makes no sense.
And Somehow they stay upright.
Everybody always watch his fucking evil
Knievel jumping over the buses with a,
with a motorcycle that probably weighed
like four to 500,000 fucking pounds.
You know, as great as that is, as
impressive as that is, you know,
to drive down the street with
all your personal belongings,
your wife and all of your
kids with that much to lose.
I don't think evil Knievel can touch that,
you know?
Cause if he wiped out,
he died. That was it.
He didn't lose fucking everything
and all his clothes. All right,
so that's wanting to grow on next
time they say evil Knievel is, is,
is the grandfather of
fucking, uh, the x games.
All right? You know, there's
always somebody else.
Everybody talks about Edison.
There's always a Tesla. I'm
sorry, what do you want from me?
I got to fill up a fucking half hour here.
I'm waiting for my salad
with a protein coming. Um,
I've been doing real well with the whole
eating and everything and I actually
got in contact with a nutritionist.
I took a long pause there for all
you guys would be like, Oh gee,
you are you going to do next? You get to
get botox. You fucking freckled can't,
Huh?
You're going to find some ginger cat and
skin it and put the fucking hair on top
of your head. Well, maybe I will.
That makes me feel better about myself.
Fuck that cat.
Never been a cat person.
Right.
You know why they have such attitudes
is cause they're allowed to shit in the
house and then they think you're on the
same level and then they're faster than
you and then it's over.
Then you can, you know,
you can instill like fucking martial
law with the water spray bottle.
You don't want to fucking do that.
Although I would enjoy doing that.
I would actually, you know, if I wasn't in
this business, I would do that as a job.
Um, is I don't like cats.
I respect him. I do,
but I would get an a lot of enjoyment
spraying water at cats that jump on the
back of couches. Is that actually
a career? Can you do that?
Is that how my life's going to end?
Wait a minute,
is that what's going to happen? I'm going
to die alone with like a cat, you know,
have a cigar,
a little glass of fucking
whiskey or something and
I'll just be sitting there in
my rocking chair spread of all these,
all these fucking cats.
So that'll be like my fucking
playstation 19 right. Cause I, you know,
I wouldn't have saved my money.
I'll have all these fucking cats and I'll
just be spraying and I'm just cackling
laughing until like Keel over like
Brando and fucking the Godfather.
Jesus built you really by know. I
don't know what it is. You know?
I was doing so well with my anger
and just late. I just fucking,
I just been losing it lately.
Fucking losing it.
I don't know. I think I need to
let it out. It's Kinda like Busan.
It's like if I don't do
it then it just builds up.
I went online yesterday looking up like
what are you, what you call that a,
it's not a fifth of Jack Daniels.
It's the smaller ones,
the little brother to that one.
That's always been my favorite.
If you just going to get fucking
hammered, he'd get that size of it. Right.
I was just talking to Nate Craig, who's,
who's going to be with me this weekend,
crushing it in front of me. I was saying,
I like that size. You're poured over on,
on the rocks. You don't get like,
there's no guilt that you're, you're,
you, you're wasting this booze that's
been in a barrel for fucking, I dunno,
since Nixon was in office and you just
sit in there and getting shit faced,
watching a baseball game. It's,
you know, it's Jack Daniels, this,
there's plenty of it. Right? And
then when you finish the bottle,
you get like a sense of accomplishment.
So that's all that not boozing
does for me. It just makes me, uh,
makes me want to booze more. And I think
like not flipping out is the same thing.
All right. Now for those of you new to
the podcast, um, if you're questioning,
did he just justify not controlling
his emotions and his drinking problem?
Yes, I did. Yes I did. And
thank you for noticing.
Um, I don't have fucking drinking
problem. I drink just fine.
What I have is a drinking buddy problem.
Can't seem to get anybody
I can fucking drink with.
That ain't going to be sitting there
counting my fucking drinks are right now.
We both went to public schools. We can
both count up to 20 Yang Preston, me.
All right.
You want to press me by fucking round.
Quit reminded me that I drove tonight.
The fuck could fucking drive that car.
My fucking sleep.
I'll back it on home.
You keep fucking talking.
That's my main or alcoholic
is a fucking redneck. Um,
anyways, oh, shout out to Chris
Hardwick. Congratulations.
They investigated and they found
out what most of us already knew.
You're a good guy.
And it was nice to see one of those
ones that seemed really sort of fucking
frivolous be investigated thoroughly
according to CNN entertainment.
And you know, that's a, that that was,
that needed to fucking happen because uh,
you know,
that whole me too movement was supposed
to be for people that were like victims.
It wasn't supposed to be,
you know,
something to be used to
get back at somebody,
you know, I don't know. I shouldn't,
I guess allegedly whenever the
fuck you're supposed to say.
But it was nice to see that AMC
took the time to investigate it,
saw that nothing happened.
They were satisfied with it
and they brought the guy back.
There you go. There you go. I hope
that this is like, you know,
cause it kinda needed that.
And then there was the initial fucking,
you know,
because nobody listened to women.
So then it just,
there was just this
floodgate of fucking anger.
You had to ride through it and just,
you knew eventually somebody who didn't
do shit was going to go down. So it's,
it's nice to see that they,
they rectified that situation.
Yeah.
I just get myself in trouble by
saying rectified. Is that too much?
Like rectal than I just,
I just advocate something you get made.
It's just a strange time, you know? Um,
anyways, um, plowing ahead here.
MMM.
Yeah.
So I forgot my God damn show shoes.
All right. Um, uh, you know,
I'm becoming Billy minimalist but not,
not on this level.
Like I like to wear a nice pair of fucking
sneakers or shoes when I do my shows
and uh,
I don't have them what I have,
I just have my fucking workout sneakers.
So I'm going to go out there looking shop
from the ankles up and then I'm going
to have these big clunky
fucking 50 year old white guy.
My feet hurt sometimes
sneakers on. So, you know,
I give it about seven minutes
before somebody heckles me.
Well now that I've put it out there,
someone's going to do it
and think they're original.
Or maybe it's their way of saying
that they listened to the podcast.
I don't know,
but I'm going to beat all of you cause
I'm just going to come out and address it.
MMM.
Anyways, you know what they
look like? They actually,
they don't even look like men's sneakers.
You know those fucking sneakers that like
old lady was old ladies with big feet
get, you know, you see them on the
bus, they just have like, you see him,
the cute little old ladies and they just
have these giant fucking sneakers over
their feet. You know what I mean?
That's what they look like. No,
they're not all white Reeboks
from the late eighties.
MMM.
Anyway, so I am really
looking forward to, uh,
I got two days here in Houston
and then I got one in Dallas. Uh,
Houston's going to be fun.
Thousand is going to be awesome,
but it's going to be a little sad.
Um,
because this is my first time going to
Dallas and with Vinnie Paul not being
around anymore and he was a big comedy
fan and he was somebody that I always
made sure I reached out to and I had a 50,
50 chance because he also lived in Vegas
that, uh, he was going to be in town,
but um, yeah, going to suck. I was just
talking to a buddy of mine who
was hanging out with Vinny, um,
just a few days before he passed and
he was saying he used to always quote
Comedians' bits and he would
always like mess him up.
He was just the funniest fucking guy
ever, man. God dammit. Um, anyways,
so I'll be going up there in,
in my mind will be
dedicating my show to him.
So that means I have to go hard,
but by the wave, I don't know how I,
I missed all of this pan terrorists shit
now that I'm like totally fucking into
them and like trying to play drums
along to their amazing music.
And um, somebody sent me the, uh,
the official video to unbroken, which
I never saw. And what I love is they,
they spent enough time on Vinny that
I saw all this shit that I was playing
wrong as far as, uh, oh,
whatever. Just, you know,
the two opening crashes, like I
didn't know he had like four crashes,
two on each side.
And then there was another part,
I thought he was playing aids and he
was playing sixties pretty fucking cool.
You don't get that a lot in music videos.
Music videos usually
barely shows the drummer.
And when they do they have the snare when
he's hitting the snare or he or she is
hitting the snare.
It's on the one in three in the bass,
the bass drums on two and four.
I cannot tell you how many fucking
times they do that. It's like,
are you even listening
to the music right now?
You're hearing the crack of the
snare and you got him fucking,
you're lining up the video
and he's hitting the fucking
bass drum. If anything,
and the music videos
genre drove me more nuts.
There wasn't anything. It was that that
they would never fucking show the drama.
And when they did they, it was
just like they didn't give a fuck.
I think they just looked at the right
hand to just line up the music and that
was it. And then, then he didn't
see what else we was fucking,
the amount of times they
cut to like the singer,
he sing in some part and you see
the drummer playing the F uh,
Phil that you don't even hear or you hear
of Phil and the guys just play in the
beat. It just, you know, oh, the fucking
guitarists does some, oh Jesus Christ.
So make sure we fucking line that up.
Note for note the singer, pay attention.
I always like fuck the drama.
So anyways,
it's a great video because they did
not do that in that video. Sorry.
Look at me getting all worked
up over nothing. So anyways,
I'm a friend of mine got me in touch with
the nutritionist and this is not code
name for a drug dealer.
Somebody just knock on my door.
Oh Jesus. Hang on a second.
Anyways,
so,
uh,
I got this fucking nutritionist cause
I wanna learn, I wanna learn how to eat
well.
Um,
you know what I mean? I don't want
to just be this guy like, hey,
I'm going to fucking cut this out and
I'm going to start fucking doing it.
You know, like I mentioned
before, like how many,
like the amount of fat fucking vegans
I'm talking like back fat,
I'm not just saying they got a
little pooch or something like that.
I'm just talking about like, you
know, just looking at people,
like you just look at him like you,
you look like you're not healthy.
And they'll be like, oh, I'm a vegetarian
or I'm fucking Vegan and all of that.
So anyways, like I mentioned, say,
bring the fucking food tray over here.
There's like,
there's so much fucking like
misinformation. I don't know how to,
I don't know how to sift through it.
And I don't want to become a vegetarian,
you know what I mean? But I also fucking
hate working out, you know what I mean?
So I would like to
fucking just eat smarter
is what I'm trying to do, you know?
Now that I'm on the fucking road,
this is what always gets me, you know,
I come in, I'm grumpy from a flight,
you know,
and you look at the salads and when
you're in a fucking bad mood and you're
hungry, a salad never looks
like the right option, does it?
It never does. What do you do? Yeah,
I'm getting a fucking burger and you're
trying to say I want a side salad.
And then the lady's like, do you want
fries with that? And then you had gone,
no bill, don't. Yeah,
do it. And then you can eat. Yeah, yeah.
Fuck it. Give me some Goddamn fries. Okay
Sir. You can order your food
without using that language.
I like to remind you all you
are in the bottle, right?
Yep. So I've been in Houston a thousand
times, so what am I supposed to do now?
Am I going to go to the fucking Alamo
again? Going into that God forsaken.
I've never even been in it.
You don't?
And I'm not talking about the
original Alamo in San Antonio.
I'm talking about the
Houston Alamo. It's a, uh,
it's a mom and pop place.
You know, I don't know what
the fuck I'm talking about.
I just wanted to just
say the different cities,
the wrong city so people
could be all like [inaudible]
shaking my head. All right, let me
read some advertising here for Y'all.
Felix Gray, y'all. Um,
even if you've never heard
of digital eye strain.
Oh Shit. Yes. Oh, this is, this is
out. Yeah. Okay. I remember this one.
This is a good one. Do you never heard
a digital eye strain? Chances? I,
chances are you've experienced the
fucking effects symptoms like eye fatigue,
dry eyes and migraines.
I'm turning the hose on your cat.
All of these things can happen when you
stare at a computer screen for too long.
Now you can profit with your
eyes and I can, oh, sorry.
Now you can protect your eyes with a
beautifully designed pair of Felix Gray
computer glasses. I want
these things. Felix.
Grays lenses are specifically designed
to filter blue light and eliminate glare
from screens.
The two main culprits,
culprits behind digital eye strain,
whether you're at work or play.
They have the blue light
filtering technology embedded
into the lens so they're
effective without the tell t telltale
yellow tint or color distortion of other
blue light filtering glasses,
Felix grays.
Y'all frames are handcrafted
from premium Italian acetate
acetate
asset tape.
I already forgot what that means.
The same material used by the biggest
designer brands in the world and they're
super stylish.
There's no prescription necessary.
Take them out of the box and slam them
on your face and get back to internet
porn.
Their glasses are available
in non prescription readers
and they just launched
prescription lenses so they
can so everyone can benefit
from wearing a pair of
Felix grace. All orders are
free shipping and free returns,
so you got nothing to lose.
Go to Felix Gray glasses.
Y'All F E L I x,
g r a y glasses.com/burr to try a
pair of Felix Gray glasses today.
That's Felix Gray,
glasses.com/burr Felix gray,
glasses.com/bar I think that I need
glasses because of these fucking computers
that and I'm 50 hey,
I'm 50 y'all.
Let's get in a truck and go fuck
a cat. Fish man. Butcher box.
Okay,
what's your body? I love that.
I believe in all the products.
Now butcher box these,
these slps butcher box delivers healthy
100% grass fed and grass finished beef
free range,
organic chicken and the top shelf.
The Johnnie Walker blue of all
meat, heritage, bread, pork.
The incredible quality I make my mouth
waters when I read this shit cause I like
to do is think about that
fucking pork chop. I apologize.
The incredible quality of butcher box
meets stats with the commitment to raising
animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they kill them.
Each box comes with at least nine to
11 pounds of meat. Fucking porn star,
which is enough for 24
individual sized meals.
You can choose from five
different box types. All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
Antibiotic Hormone free.
Uh,
butcher box believes in healthier food
system where everyone has access to meets
the way nature intended.
Free of antibiotics and hormones and
humanely raised on an open pasture before
we kill them.
Selection butcher box carefully curates
the finest selection and cuts and makes
it a breeze to customize
your own delivery.
Build your own box to get exactly
what you and your family love.
Choose your delivery frequencies
with customizable subscriptions.
However you want to do this.
Recipes available, butcher box,
website and videos are available to follow
along on butcher box youtube channel.
I had the pork. It was unbelievable.
I loved it. Okay. Anyways,
um, it's a lot of words here
to receive free bacon for life.
The nerve of Jim Jefferies to say that,
that,
that this is not the
greatest country of all time.
Free Bacon for life and the
Good Bacon American Bacon,
not Canadian Bacon. The good shit, uh,
of scripts.
Free braking for life of subscription.
What that's wrong that to
receive free bacon for life
of subscription. Oh, F plus $10 off
your order. Go to butcher box.com.
Click on the big bacon banner on the
homepage and use bird checkout. Go now.
Limited time offer. All
right, stitch Fitch, fix.
Sorry.
Stitch fix.
Stitch fix has reimagined the
way we we find and buy clothes.
First of all,
hats off to these guys.
No Pun intended that they took the time
to figure out how to fix this boring
problem. Um, we've reimagined
it like Disney convenience,
stitch fix understands
that life gets busy.
So just tell them your sizes and your
favorite types of clothes and how much you
want to spend and your personal stylist
will pick out your clothing for you
based on your preferences.
Try before buying.
If an item doesn't fit or you just don't
like it, no worries. Just send it back.
Free of charge style. Some of
us have it, some of us don't.
But just because a sense of style seems
elusive for some doesn't mean it's
impossible to obtain to attain.
Sorry.
There's no time like the present to
discover that style you never knew you had
and you can with a little help
from our friends at stitch fix.
This is like when they would go into the
musical montage in any eighties movie
when they would be like re
remaking the nerdy chick. You know,
she wasn't good looking because she
wore glasses and had our hair up right.
Then they'd let the hair down and take
the glasses off. It's like, oh my God,
Megan, you're beautiful. This is what
stitch fix is going to do for you.
Stitch fix has reinvented how we bought,
find and buy clothes.
Just answer some basic questions about
your size, his favorite styles and budget.
I feel like they already said this right
from your laptop, smart phone or tablet.
You're personalized stylist then
springs into action. I Christ they got,
I know their order. Hand selecting five
brand new clothing items just for you.
I now lie.
Now personal stylist sounds like something
only the rich and famous can afford,
but you can't to stitch fix styling fee
is only 20 bucks which is applied as a
credit towards anything
you keep and sense.
Your personal stylist uses only your
personal preferences to to pick your
clothes, your still in complete
control. Once your items have arrived,
try him on and pay for what you keep.
Don't like something, need another size.
Just send the items back.
Grouse, no questions asked.
And shipping is always free both ways.
Get your fix wherever you want or sign
up to receive a scheduled shipments.
The choice is yours.
You're going to love stitch fix and
MMM.
What is it?
How are we to stitch fix stitch,
fix.com/ [inaudible] to get started now,
keep all,
fight up five items in your box and
you'll get 25% off your entire purchase.
That stitch
fix.com/bar hey,
stitch fix.com/burr.
All right. Um, okay.
So anyways,
I'm on the road.
I just sorted a salad and I got the beef.
Yeah,
I probably should got the chicken
has got fish but a fish yesterday.
And you know what?
I always forget to tell him,
don't send me the fucking dinner rolls.
And now they got them all warm
underneath the Napkin with some butter.
And My mother taught me not to waste.
So what am I supposed to do here?
Huh?
I Dunno. Anyways, but I'm, I'm uh,
I'm liking the way I look right now.
I get irritated. So I
would like to continue, uh,
with the nok booze and for a while,
I'm not going to do with like the
way I smoke cigars like a chimney.
Now I'm going to drink the way I
smoke cigars, which is, you know,
once every 10 minutes. No, once
every 10 to 14 days I have a cigar.
So I would like to get hammered or have
a couple of cocktails twice a month.
That's not bad. 24 times
a year, 24 times a year.
I just want to remind my liver
that this is not a game. Okay.
The preseason is over. All right. So
keep your head on a fucking swivel.
Stay on you, God damn toes. Um, I like,
I got a night coming up. I'm going
to come off the wagon for one day.
Like what I would like to do, come up
to the wagon for one day in August,
and then I am not going to drink again
until I'm going to a Michigan Wolverine
game this year at the big house.
Oh
so
Jay Jay,
I have not been to a game there
since 1999 and the only guy,
there was some guy in Michigan I believe
when the Heisman and I for some reason
I remember that Guy David Boston,
cause he had the last name Boston and
then he went to the charges or something
like that. I can't remember.
But uh, I went to the uh,
Michigan Ohio state game,
you know,
the big fucking rivalry game at the
big house. That's a, that's a good one.
I've been to some good ones, man.
I've been to that one. I went to a,
what is it, the fucking, uh,
Texas versus Oklahoma upended that one.
I never been to USC. Ucla. That's
fucked it been out here for so long,
but the one I would love to go to,
I want to go to Alabama. Auburn.
I've seen Lsu or Alabama.
I've seen Texas a and
m with Johnny Football
First Alabama. I just like, you know,
those fucking sec games are the
best. Um, I shouldn't have said that.
Anomalous and everybody who will show
you big Taylor's book either. I get it.
I get it. You're, you're, you're partial
to where the fuck you're from. All right.
That's the podcast here. I got
to go do my fucking show. Uh,
I hope you guys have a wonderful Thursday
and a great weekend. You Con, uh,
the music that we're going to be using
is a Darren king. He did it cover of,
uh, is it Richie haven? Is that
his name? The guy from Woodstock.
He did it cover of his freedom.
Um,
if you guys want to know who
this artist is staring king and,
uh, he's done everything. He used to play
drums with mute math. He plays guitar,
he sings.
And from what I've heard,
he's going to be maybe doing
a small tour coming up. Um,
but I'm a big fan of this guy
is just like incredible artists.
So enjoy the music. And then we'll have
a half hour greatest hits from, yeah,
Thursday afternoon podcast just
before Monday from a Thursday.
I don't know, a couple of years
ago, maybe from earlier this year.
I don't know how it fucking works. All
right. Have a great weekend. You can't.
And I'll see on Monday.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I got a break time in Vegas other
than when I went down to the pool,
because I go down to the pool, I'm down
there to me, it's fucking j law had,
who has been killing it
in front of me. And, uh,
the lovely Nia and her cousins and
were, hang all right cousin. I mean,
and we're hanging out, down the pool and
they're doing the usual shit, you know,
if you're a redhead and
he'd go down to the pool,
like you just asked it for people all,
you know,
look how white you are. You
know, like, I never noticed.
It's like I'm fucking around myself.
I've been around myself since the sixties,
the late sixties.
I know how white I am,
and if I ever forget how white I am,
there's always somebody
there to remind me. Sorry,
I don't know if you've noticed your
skin tone. What am I meditating?
Floating up on my body? All right,
so these people up with go, c'mon,
c'mon in the pool and like,
I don't want to go in the pool.
I don't want to go on the fucking
pool. You know, they're like, why? No,
why don't you want to go to the pool?
You know why? Because the fucking
look at, look at these people, look at
them, look at them. And you're getting,
you're getting your, you know,
would you take a bath with all,
with any one of the
people that you see here,
these fucking just masses of human beings.
There's not enough chlorine in a fucking
pool to kill whatever the fuck they're
dragging in the pool. You know, it's
like I finally end up going to the pool.
Then everybody made fun of how white my
fucking alabaster chest was a da that I
had to stay in the shade of the
fucking, uh, the lifeguard's chair,
you know,
I had a show to do, I'm
being a professional, I
can't come out stage later,
half in the bag, looking
like a lot of stuff, right?
I gotta do my little song and dance
later on that night. So, anyway,
so I ended up getting in the fucking
pool against my, what I wanted to do,
you know, and then I
get out of the pool. Uh,
first of all for my age,
I am in absolutely phenomenal.
Top shelf shape.
Alright.
I gotta tell you the fucking,
just the stuff.
Fuck the humanity that I
saw poolside in Las Vegas,
the fucking humanity
keyword manatee.
Yeah.
Not The skep step on a Jim Gaffigan.
I just realized he used to use that
reference and I'm pretty sure he used it.
I can't remember how the fuck he used it,
but if he used it to
describe a fat Pale Torso,
not really pale, but whatever, whatever
the fucking shit. I saw the side of the,
he was dead on that.
Oh my God.
Is there anything worse than seeing
a tattoo come of age? You know,
Jesus Christ, if you get
a tattoo, you better.
You better just make the mental decision
that you're going to p nine dx for the
rest of your fucking life.
Cause when you don't do it,
I saw this guy down at the pool.
All right.
He had like not only the worst
tattoos you've ever seen in your life,
like the worst placement,
you know what I mean?
Like you get one like on the side
of your arm up by your shoulder,
that looks good, right on the
bicep. That looks good. You know,
geo,
somebody got gets one right over there.
Voicebox like I don't give a fuck
what you have surrounding that.
That leads into that part of the,
of the, of the work or the piece,
whatever they call it. It looks fucking
horrible. Leg Tattoos, horrific,
horrific.
So this fucking jerk off.
He has basically the exact sort of
like tribal thing that the rock has,
except he doesn't look tribal. He
looks like an accountant, you know,
and he doesn't work out.
So just imagine if the
rock was his pasty as I was
and it never worked down in his life.
But he has that same tattoo that
starts at the elbow, goes up the arm,
over the shoulder and
covers one whole peck.
But the way this guy had it done was
it didn't cover his whole packet,
came swinging in and went right above his,
his man nipple.
So now all of the,
all of that is like colored in.
So because of the pasting as of his torso,
your eye is just drawn
to his right nipple.
Yeah.
Is he standing in the fucking pool?
My neck was sore from shaking
my head at people. It was,
it was absolutely fucking
horrific. Right? So, so anyways,
um, I go back up to the, uh, I go back
up to the hotel room. Right? You know,
you gotta make sure that I'm all shipshape
from my goddamn show and I put on the
news and what do they end
up doing a story about?
They start doing a story
about the amount of, uh,
fecal matter found in public pools
right after I just got out of a God pool.
You know,
and I know what people always think,
oh, stay away from where the kids are.
Stay away from the Kitty Pool.
Right. Stay away from that.
They always blamed the fucking kids.
Will I,
you know something after seeing
what I saw poolside, you know,
there weren't a lot of kids in there,
but I guarantee you
somebody's got a cola. I know this is
fucking disgusting. But people you've,
you're basically bathing, you
don't see even more fucked up. His,
his Vegas is just like, you know,
people fly in from all over the world.
You're taking a fucking aids bath,
you know, with a shot of fucking,
ah,
what the hell was that shit that came out,
but to kill people so fast
that it just burned out.
Everybody just ran into the woods.
The fuck was that shit called.
Oh Christ.
I can't remember a bola.
That's it with a shot
of Ebola or whatever.
Food poisoning. I don't know what
it is. A salmon, Ellis shower,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
I'm done with public pools.
The only pool that I will ever
swimming again is my pool.
If I ever get one or the pool of some
hot chick that I want to fucking bang
cause I have Nias permission.
That's the only way it's going to go down.
Other than that, you know, I'll
just go, I'll just go take a bath.
Yeah.
That
way I'm out of the sun. You know,
we'll take a couple of vitamin E pills,
whatever the fuck it is you get from
the sun, other than skin cancer,
I'm done with it.
You know what America needs to implement
after years and years of calling the
French people smelly.
You know?
That's Kinda like the thing when we went
over to France and save their ass for
the second time last century. Oh wait, did
we do it once? We did it one time, right?
I can't fucking remember.
So anyways,
we always made fun of the French father.
They smell.
If you ever watched a bugs bunny
growing up, man, you saw pepe Le Pew.
If you noticed he had a French accent,
you know,
that's the kind of shit you couldn't
get away with today because of political
correctness. I guess they were basically
saying that you know that they stunk.
But I'll tell you one thing would that
the French have when it comes to hygiene
over Americans, all right? Is the big day.
All right? I can guarantee you if I
ever go swimming in a public pool again,
it's going to be good friends.
Ellis is a bunch of Americans are,
I know, I've been over to England,
I never saw but day over there,
you know,
but day is basically a car
wash for your asshole Ed. Uh,
you know,
it leaves you feeling refreshed,
puts a fucking smile on your face and
evidently had French is so fucking happy.
You forget.
Yeah,
put on Deodorant. But I'll tell you
right now, you can jump in that pool.
I bet the next debt back then I'm
talking about that shit over there.
[inaudible]
pen
not chose.
[inaudible]
Hey, how are ya? It's built bar and it is
the Monday morning podcasts from Monday,
July 26th, 2010 look at that
Honda last Monday in July,
another summer month flying by.
And once again there they are,
the goddamn bank or cuts
just staring you in the face,
sticking their hands out there.
A little grubby fucking hands asking
for another pound of flesh as they do at
the end of every month.
Don't they actually talked to a buddy
mine who outside the business and got a
check the other day, right? And was,
you know, bitching about the taxes.
I talking about all the taxes taken
out and he goes, thanks a lot Obama,
you know,
and then I get into a fucking argument
trying to get this dude to stop blaming
the standing fucking president.
You got to get to the fucking guys
who put put, put the dude in there.
Not even put the dude in there but
can take the dude out. You know,
doesn't fucking make a difference. I
remember I voted for Ron Paul. You know,
I always vote for those guys.
Ralph Nader's and all that.
The Ross Perot's and everybody always,
they always tells me it's a fucking
waste of a vote. Is it though?
You tell me one fucking thing different
that Obama's doing that McCain wouldn't
be doing. I know there's little subtle
differences, you know, he's going to,
rather than giving it to the fucking rich,
he's going to give it to the fucking
poor. You know, both their philosophy suck
and I'll in bankers just keep
getting richer and fucking richer.
It just, it just blows my mind.
You know, it's one thing I've,
I've learned finally figured out over
all this shit, that whole rich guy,
we'll give it to the rich and they'll
create jobs and it'll trickle down.
The keyword is trickle and we're all
going to be sitting there with their
tongues. Ah, Eh, trying to catch
a drop of fucking prosperity.
And then on the other side,
if you just give people shit,
you don't help them. They come back
the next day like a fucking cat,
you know, waiting for another
bowl of milk. It's like, no dude,
I was trying to give you nourishment
so you could go fucking, you know,
have enough strength to go milk a cow
wherever the fuck you supposed to do. Oh,
I didn't know.
I don't you going to give a dog.
This is where I get the free milk from.
All right Dan, I get the fuck out of here.
Fucking piece of shit.
You know, anybody got a,
I've got a got a bomb for a
friend always asking for money.
Do you ever do that?
And you're doing well in your life and
you feel guilty and they get themselves
into a jam. Man, I'm in
a fucking jam, you know,
and it's everybody's fucking fault.
But theirs and their girls got them on
the outs and the cops fucking arrested
'em and air. They're going to put
them in fucking jail. You know,
or whatever's going to happen.
They're going to take their fucking car
and they need 500 bucks and you fucking
give it to him, right? What do you do?
They get out of that jam for fucking 10
minutes and what within a month they're
in another fucking jam if
they learned anything. No,
and a lot of times it's
an even worse predicament.
I'm going to stop saying jam
like I'm in the fucking seventies
started off me doing the character.
I'm in a jam.
And then I just started saying it is me.
And I felt like fucking the dude who
drives the mystery machine on Scooby Doo.
I say that he was too much
of a square, right?
Fucking the hot chicken,
the missionary position.
Am I really doing Scooby Doo jokes?
Um, the fuck was his name.
Was it Fred with his ascot?
That's all I'm saying, dude.
It's all fucking bullshit.
I believe there's plenty of fucking money
if these fucking banker assholes will
stop taking all of it in
these corporations. I Dunno.
Does it, does it really cost?
Well, it really costs like
fucking 40 bucks a tee shirt.
If you pay somebody a
decent wage to make it,
they really got to have some eight year
old make $3 a fucking day, you know,
isn't there a of fucking
middle ground? Yeah, I,
I don't get it.
I just don't get it. I, I just refused.
I don't blame politicians anymore.
Democrat or Republican. I
just don't fucking blame him
anymore. It's an absolute,
it's a fucking shit storm.
And look at,
look at a shitstorm Obama came
walking into, that's like, yeah,
you're hosting one of those hoarders
shows and you walk into the house and it's
just piled high was shit.
Trillions of fucking
things that need to be thrown
out. Right? And then what?
You give the guy 10 minutes to clean out
the fucking house and then after that
it's his mess.
Look at a fucking mess you made.
I don't fucking know. I gotta I gotta
admit like politics is just like baseball.
I stopped watching in June of last year,
you know,
although I'm starting
to come around again,
I'm coming back around
to baseball and I'm, um,
I'm in the nationals and I'm
liking the Pittsburgh pirates.
I'm coming back into the fucking backdoor.
All right,
going, I'm going down to tier three.
I'm bored shitless with Yankees,
red sox. I got to at, I'm fucking burned
out and burned out with this shit.
It's just like whatever.
We won the fucking world series.
Then we want another one that's the
end of the movie. Roll the credits.
I got to fucking try to give a shit.
They act like I give a fuck
12 times a goddamn year.
Um, I don't know. Yeah, but I don't
watch politics either. Um, I just, uh,
and those though, those political
fucking shows on TV, I just,
I can't get into them because,
uh,
there's nobody really taken the people
that I feel need to be taken to task.
And at the end of the day,
the people I feel need to be taken to task
are, uh, it's, it's all based on
shit I watched on youtube, you know,
so who the fuck am I?
Right,
bitch. So I just tapped out. I
just said, you know what? Fuck it.
Fuck it.
I'm going to get myself a bear.
Okay. You know, maybe get a pistol.
Learn how to shoot the fucking thing.
You know what a beer sounds
really good right now.
If I ever drank a beer
on the fucking podcast,
I think I'm going to think I'm
going to go fucking get one.
Do I got time to go run and get it? You
know what? It's not one of those bears.
You can really drink out of a fucking
can you get a pour it into a glass
and I, you know what? I have the ability
to hit pause, don't I? I really do.
Let me see if I know how to do it
here. Ah, Jesus. This is always tough.
Do I hit play? Oh, I
hit record. Hit record.
All right.
And with the magic of the pause button,
I am back and I got a fucking
brew right in front of me.
Huck too is what I'm doing.
I don't give a shit anymore.
I gave a fuck and a all you end
up doing it. You just start.
You just start yelling at people in
bars. That's all given a fuck. Get you.
You know what are you gonna make a sign?
Staying on some street corner.
Honk. If you give a fuck, that's,
that's going to stop the banks.
You can't do it. I quit. I give up.
I don't give a shit.
Just tell me what to believe.
I don't fucking care anymore.
I want to get a gun though.
I really do stand on my fucking
porch waving it at people.
Just be that guy. We always knew who
he was going to be a problem. I mean,
you had a gun. I got a gun too. What?
I'm responsible. I'll keep it in. Uh,
keeping him a safe that way.
If somebody breaks in, uh,
I go, can you wait a second? I've
never understood that. You know,
it's like if you're going to
have a fucking gun, you know,
to really protect yourself,
don't you have to sleep with it?
Like fucking Tony Soprano in the second
to last episode on the Soprano's when
you thought this Tony Montana ending
was going to happen and then it didn't.
I don't get tissue.
Keep it in the gun safe.
And then you keep the bullets
in the trunk of your car, right?
You keep the scope up in the attic,
you know,
as, as the intruders chasing
you around your fucking house,
you grabbing different parts of the gun,
assembling it,
stick it under your fucking pillowcase.
Like Beretta is not what
you're supposed to do.
You know what?
I've never owned a nightstand in my life.
I'm going to get a gun too. This is a, I
should have done this on the 4th of July.
I'm doing a podcast.
I'm talking about getting a gun and I'm
drinking a fucking beer and I one of
those pussy ones.
Either he's a fucking s one
pint Boddington's pub Ale.
You know one of those ones,
you open it up and it's got that fucking,
I don't know what it has in there.
That metal ball that rattles around
you look in, you can never find it.
They had no idea what it is,
but for some reason you never had the
curiosity enough to fucking gut the can to
see what it looks like. I like the
mystery. I like the mystery of it.
I don't know what it is.
Isn't it weird how a fucking beer
like quenches your thirst and then
automatically makes you thirsty again
once the deal is or cools, it's, Ooh,
Ooh. Um, speaking of guns,
Oh, what'd you guys do? If I just got
absolutely shit faced on this podcast,
I'd feel great and I wouldn't even
think that I had a drinking problem.
I can just keep hitting pause.
You guys wouldn't even know.
And technically because I'm talking to
you. I'm not drinking alone. All right?
Isn't that what George Thorogood went
off the fucking rails when he did that
song. I drink alone. The adweek Lune
rally and he started putting on the weight
and he still wear those rattle snake
skin fucking pants with matching top,
you know, at some point, I mean, dude, I,
I should fucking talk.
I should really talk with my fucking,
my God Damn Ma round.
Smooth white belly is fucking beer at
Goddamn quarter to nine at night's not
going to help.
At least it's hot as fuck in here.
You know my old bastard fucking
neighbor downstairs is home and I like,
I bring my voice down because
I don't need the bullshit.
I can't fucking wait. You know, I got
a new special coming out. All right,
it's coming out in September and I get
a fail on this going to fucking hit and
it's going to hit hard and I'm finally
going to go out and buy a gun damn house
out here and a day I do when I
load up that fucking you all right.
You liked that. Even though I'm
dreaming about buying a house,
I'm still a broke ass hole and I have to
move my shit myself when I load up that
you all okay?
And I bring that fucking tailgate
down one last time. All the way down.
That little fucking he little bumper,
that's only an inch off the ground to
make it easier for pussies like me to load
their bureau in there.
You know,
I'm going to ring his doorbell and I'm
going to get in his face and be like,
listen old man.
I don't know when.
I don't know how,
but I'm going to fucking get back.
I'm going to do something to you.
I don't know what the fuck I'm gonna I,
you know I sound, I sound like
fucking jumping Jeff Farmer right now.
I'm coming at you full force.
You turn the tables on me
in the wrong way. Old Man.
No, I don't know. I, I can I, you
know, I don't do the revenge thing.
I told you that guys a long time
ago. I don't do it. You know,
if I wasn't so worried that
he'd have a heart attack,
I really want to scare him one day.
Just do a fake sneeze,
right close to him,
make them shit his pants a little bit,
you know, take a Geritol shit
and it's fucking Dickies.
Miserable bastard
really is.
He's really the fucking ghost of a, was
it future? Was that the one that was, uh,
I dunno what the fuck he is.
All right, let's move on here.
I talked about getting a gun and so on.
And this is a thing too,
because I'm doing this
podcast so early in the week,
um, you know, I, I actually,
I went through a bunch of
old emails and you know,
I get a ton of emails
from you guys and uh,
and I know sometimes people get
upset when I don't read them.
I just get a ton of emails, but I just
went back because it's only Thursday.
So I didn't really have that
many current ones. And I, uh,
I saw some gems that I missed.
And I guess one week I was talking
about the amount of people that
Stalin had killed. Verse Hitler.
And how come people when they bring
up evil, they don't talk more about
Yosef Stalin considering it,
it seems to me that he killed like
three times plus a little bit more.
I mean what, what, what exactly
are Hitler's uh, exact numbers?
Cause I know the says that they killed
six on 6 million, 600. Jesus Christ,
6 million Jewish people.
But I also know that he killed gaze.
He killed, uh, uh, I think he killed
blacks. If there's only blacks in Germany.
Um, maybe some Catholics,
I dunno, whatever. Traders,
people who helped out Jewish
people. I mean, what do, I mean,
did he get another fucking
million out of that?
I don't know what his exact number is,
but I'm pretty safe.
It's pretty safe to say that it's
under 10 million. So I was saying like,
you know, Joseph Yosef Style and know
where the fuck you said it. You know this,
this son of a bitch killed
like twice as many of that.
If he give Hitler 10 million.
All right.
So that was basically what I
was riffing on. So this game,
this game made a great point. He
actually wrote to me and he said, um,
I ran across something I thought
you might find interesting. Uh,
I know you how you talk about Hitler
versus Mussolini Versus Stalin and the
number of drug deaths attributed
to each one of them. Well,
I don't think they actually
did much of the dirty work.
They outsourced it to a Indian kids
who did it for half the price. Hahaha.
And it's actually a decent joke.
If I read it better, I'm seriously,
they had it done and they
didn't do it themselves.
So thinking about the fact that they
didn't do much of the dirty work got me
thinking about who did the dirty work
for themselves. After a little research,
I came across,
uh,
the person who I think was the baddest
motherfucker of World War Two and a,
I love the suspense. He builds
up. Was He from the u s no.
Was He from Germany? Ah. Was
He from England? No Cigar.
Mother fucker. Was He from
Finland? Finland, fuck yeah.
Does evidently do was from Finland.
The guy's name was,
and I'm going to butcher this because even
the, the, the phonetic pronunciation, I,
I don't know how to say the guy's
name. Uh, maybe anybody in Finland.
And what's a fuck is in, is that
Helsinki? I have no fucking idea. Uh, um,
CMO. Hey Ha. I don't know how the
fuck to say. My best attempt at the,
at the pronunciation of the last name is,
what did he say?
How high as in hat head,
how Ha Cmo, how hair, I don't know.
Anyways,
he was nickname white death due to the
fact that he would operate in the snow
and at a completely white uniform so
he couldn't be seen. All right, let's,
let's go onto the Wikipedia. Let me read
about this guy. The first thing you know,
if you look at, look at, look,
this guy up, it's s. I. M o h.
A. Y. H.
A M live to be a 96 years old.
All right.
Nicknamed the white death by the Russians
is highest recorded number of kills.
He was a sniper was 505.
He has the highest recorded number
of kills 505 kills in any major war.
All right. Uh, before entering
combat, he was a farmer and a hunter.
His farmhouse was reportedly full
of trophies for marksmanship.
So I guess he was a natural, he was kinda
like the Wayne Gretzky of killing shit.
Right. Um, it was during war, the world,
the winter war in 1939 to 1940
between Finland and the Soviet Union.
Isn't that interesting? Interesting.
They call it the winter war. Um,
or maybe that was an aspect of World
War II. I have no idea. Anyways,
the winter war,
uh,
that he began his duty as a sniper and
fought for the Finnish army against the
Red Army and temperatures of minus
40 and minus 20 degrees Celsius.
So what's that like 80 degrees Fahrenheit?
I have no idea. It's fucking cold out.
Um, dress completely in white camouflage.
Hey Ha, whatever the fuck his call,
his name. Hey Ya. Uh,
was credited with 505 confirmed
kills of Soviet soldiers.
542 unconfirmed.
If unconfirmed deaths are included,
the unofficial finished frontline
figure with the battlefield,
battlefield of Cola places the
number of his kills at over 800
cause I guess he also had a submachine
gun and people give them credit for
killing another 200 people,
thus bringing his credits up
to at least 705 remarkably,
this is the biggest thing here.
This mother fucker did this in fewer
than a hundred days with very limited
amount of daylight per day.
So he just sort of woke up,
I guess. You know, he's killing
like seven people a day.
If he's up for 16 hours
once every couple hours.
Uh, what else can I
say about this guy? Um,
I missed the part where he got to formed
part of the way through there. He was a,
I'm gonna fuck is it now?
The tech to hae a was to compact the snow.
You can pack the snow in front of him so
that the shot wouldn't disturb the snow
and reveal his position.
He also kept snow in his mouth so that
when breathing this steam would not give
them away. How have they not
made a movie about this guy?
He preferred to you as iron sights rather
than telescopic sites for all you gun
nuts to present a smaller target.
Uh Oh,
I see.
Cause the sniper must raise his head
higher when using a telescopic sight to
prevent visibility risks. A telescopic
sights glass can fog up easily.
Okay.
[inaudible] the Soviets tried a
number of ways to get rid of him.
Counter sniper's artillery
strikes and filing. On May six,
the guy was shot through the jaw during
combat by a Russian soldier. The,
the bullet tumbled upon
impact and left his head.
Fellow soldier picked him up.
Half his head was missing.
He regained consciousness
seven days later,
the day peace was declared. Shortly
after the war, uh, this dude was,
went straight from corporal
to a second lieutenant,
the highest jump and rank in the
history of the Finnish army. Uh, wow.
Did that board, I'll be like, I didn't
bore you guys too much, but uh, they,
you go and they asked him later on
in life, did, did it bother you?
The amount of people that you kill,
which is such a Douchey fucking question.
And he just basically said, look, I
was doing the job they told me to do.
Like they all end up fucking same.
Did it bother you?
Did it bother me that I killed the guys
who were trying to kill me? Uh, no,
it didn't.
I'm sure a couple of dumb fucks who
thought they were in the clear and got up
and took a Piss,
you know,
and he kind of felt bad like Jesus
Christ do Kaylee's pissed behind a tree,
you know, maybe that wouldn't make
you feel bad. What are you guys think?
Do you think you'd feel bad?
Um,
I would just think if I went to war,
I've always felt this,
that the second the battle started,
I would be,
I would be the guy crying in the Fox hole,
but if I could ever just kill that first
fucking person, I would just be like,
all right, well, you know,
fuck it now. And, uh,
I just think I would be so
filled with anger and fear that,
uh, I dunno. I Dunno. That's,
and I have no fucking, you know,
those people who fight in wars, man,
people would join the service.
Jesus Christ. I don't know.
I, I don't think I could.
And you know, as much as people sit
there and they talk about, you know,
the balls it takes to do stand up,
you know,
it, it really pales in fucking
comparison when, you know,
if you just talk about someone who goes
into the Peace Corps is trying to bring
water to a try, forget about
somebody who's fucking going
to war. And speaking of,
let's talk about standup terminology.
Here's something that, um,
has been bugging me lately
is I've noticed that, um,
and this happens, you know, people
come up with new words like a,
you know,
I'm chilling,
I'm going to use like hip hop slang
because that's always the easiest.
You know what,
I get this old ones,
I can really think of it then they just
become words. But, uh, just as, as a,
as a stand up comic purest I've noticed,
you know,
when I get into it with the crab,
when somebody heckles me and then
I give him shit back, I get emails.
I was at your second show,
sat on Saturday night.
I loved the way you heckled guy in
the audience after he heckled you.
Um,
heckling is done by the crowd.
The comedian does not heckle the crowd.
He can play with the
crowd and he can fucking,
I don't even know what it's called. When
you, when you fucking murderer a heckler,
you destroy them, but you're
not heckling them. All right?
You're up there trying to do your rec.
The only way for a comedian to,
to heckle a crowd as if he,
if he sat in the crowd and the hope and
the whole crowd got up on stage and then
tried to do some to some
sort of performance and I
interrupted and fucked up
their performance. But when they
tell me to go fuck themselves,
fuck myself, they're
not heckling me. Jesus.
You would think that I would actually
have the decency to look up heckle.
Why don't I do that?
Heckle definition?
Goddamn at that beer tasted
good and I get a fucking 6:54 AM
definition for heckle.
Uh, okay. Here we go.
Try to embarrass and annoyed by questions.
Jibes or objections.
Badger try to annoy someone speaking
or performing in public by questions.
Jibes or objections and
bad. There you go. See,
that's why you can't because you're not
trying to perform in public. All right,
I skipped over the shit in parentheses.
So let me read that again. Try to,
Heckerling is trying to embarrass and
annoy someone speaking or performing in
public by questions. Jibes or
objections, badger or whatever.
That's what it means.
So the comedian can't heckle the crowd
because the crowd is not on stage trying
to give a performance.
So for the love of God,
stop sending me fucking emails saying
you loved how I heckled the crowd.
I didn't do that. It's like telling
a guitarist, I love your drum solo.
Did they make any sense as this
alcohol taking place? I haven't drank.
I haven't fucking eight in a minute.
You know this beer is fucking delicious.
You know what makes a beer like this?
Tastes go to good beer glass.
Do you guys have beer glasses?
Talking to the men out there and the few
women out there who are a fuck you guys.
Women aren't into beer glasses,
are you? You know what I mean?
Lesbians on my podcast, maybe you guys
have the brains to like beer glasses.
Um, Jesus Christ. You know, I
usually don't make any sense,
but me buzz doing this podcast is
going to make even less and less sense.
That's a fucking sign of maturity. A
beer glass. And that's another thing.
If you want to stave off the fact
that you kind of think that you have a
drinking problem is if in your house,
if you have the proper glasses for
whatever alcohol you're drinking,
okay, you're drinking whiskey
out of a disc Dixie Cup.
Let me stutter in like a shit head.
That was a good line too.
If you're drinking whiskey out
of a Dixie Cup, take to uh, yeah,
there's really no way,
you know,
a little vodka in a sippy cup.
She kids crying in the corner
because he's fucking hungry.
Uh, hang on one second. Hang on a second.
What are we going? What do I got here?
Hey Paul, let me call you back. I'm doing
my podcast. All right. All right man.
Take it easy. Um, all
right. Where the fuck am I?
Yeah. You know what I mean? But if you
have the right, you have the proper glass.
I have the classic 16 ounce,
you know,
you'd pour a Heineken
in this type of thing.
I actually got those
Sam Adams glasses too.
You know the ones that they had where
they got some sort of special glass thing
at the bottom and it makes the beers,
you know, the Sam Adams Swirl up,
they're really cool glasses. But what I
don't like as they only hold 12 ounces,
you know, and it's just
like, well, what about me?
Who likes to go 16 ounces at a time?
You know?
All right.
I'm not even being funny right now.
I'm just fucking sitting here enjoying a,
there's nothing better.
One Nice fucking beer.
But can you ever stop?
You know what's funny is my
girl's not here right now.
He'd be funny if I'm just sitting here
in my fucking boxers and just, just,
she comes home and I'm about ready to
go on the road for another five days and
then she just comes home and I'm just
fucking sitting here buzzed, you know,
t shirt, boxers, socks. I mean,
I'm just dressed like I'm unemployed.
Then all I gotta do is just start giving
a shit. Why am I such a Dick? All right,
let's continue on here. Um, yeah,
that would be on sightful
in our speaking of shit.
That's just fucking on sightful to use a,
a,
a segue from the 1980s,
I was flying back from New York and uh,
you know,
it's a real pet bait.
Pet peeve of mine is these,
these motherfucking like regular
look and people who just get here,
they kicked his shoes off
during the flight. All right?
And then not wearing any socks.
All right?
So it's gross enough that you have your
bare feet on that airline carpet were
God knows what is in the rug.
Okay.
You know how filthy the fucking
errors in the Goddamn tube,
they never recycled that fucking
air. You're just breathing. I mean,
it's like 80% carbon dioxide,
right?
So what the fuck you think is in the rug?
If you ever seen him shampoo a goddamn
rug in between flights, they don't do it.
And you put your bare feet on this. What
kills me? This is regular fucking people.
After, after they've kicked his shoes
off, they have to go to the bathroom.
They get up and they,
they walked down the aisle
into the bathroom with no
fucking socks or shoes on.
So most disgusting. I saw
this girl sitting next to
me. She had one of those, uh,
English Australian can't
pick out the accent,
you know,
the next time you fucking European
shit on what animals, we are over here.
One of your fucking, when you fucking
birds who is sitting next to me,
got up with their flip flops
on now, kicked him off. And
then while she actually,
I'll give her credit. She did walk halfway
to the bathroom and then came back,
you know, and I was like, all
right, she has some class,
but she had her hair up and
she had flakes behind her ear.
Just disgusting the whole fucking flight,
and I could stop looking at it every time
I'd glance over and then I would just
keep making these noises going.
Ah.
Then she sort of glance at me and I
pretend like I didn't do what she probably
thought I had Tourette's and she didn't
realize that I'm reacting to the fucking
the fucking flakes behind you. You're
kind of a mother. Are you going to be,
you can't even clean behind
your own fucking years.
Put your head down and go walk
barefoot to the fucking airplane,
goddamn bathroom and clean yourself
up before I slap the shit out of you.
All right, what else do
we got here? All right.
Here's a good youtube video for the
week as the fucking booze is starting to
kick in a Boddingtons,
I highly recommend it.
All right? You youngsters out there,
you're probably not gonna like it. Um,
all right.
But as your voice gets deeper and your
ball stuck to drop even further into the
toilet bowl, I'm telling you it's a
bear. You're going to fucking like,
what am I doing here? What the
hell am I? All right. Note to self,
don't drink when you do the
podcast anymore. What did
you guys enjoy? Podcasts?
So I just got completely shit faced.
The thing is, is it's only an hour long,
so it's kind of hard to get drunk that
quick. I can get pretty buzzed, you know,
really bill, is that what we're here?
We're down to right now was like,
you're going to do like some fucking
stunt like David Blaine. Bill,
why don't you do the podcast and a
fucking block of ice? You'd dumb cunt.
I think it's time for a
special guest at some point.
I gotta I gotta get another special
guest on this podcast. Um, all right,
plowing ahead here. Um, here's a
youtube video to watch for this week.
Ah,
baby preacher with subtitles.
Uh,
it's just fucking awesome.
It's a a, I dunno, this
baby who that guest is,
goes to church every fucking day and
his watch these preachers preaching and
then they gave the baby the Mike and it's
just sort of walking around going, Eh,
eh,
talking baby talk.
But somebody transcribes what the kid
is saying and I swear to God it the way
they put it up there it
right as you read it. The baby says
it and it sounds like the baby saying,
and it's fucking, and it's a visual
joke and I'm trying to explain it here.
All right. Underrated.
Overrated for this week.
I'm doing this at a half hour in knowing
full well that I have to somehow fill
up another 20 fucking minutes.
All right.
Overrated for this week.
This is a great one.
Overrated wind chimes is,
Dude says,
I hate the annoying clink clank
sound with a fucking passion.
What is wrong with the people? Huh?
What's wrong with people? Seriously,
the world is not loud.
You have to fucking add to it.
You know they,
they do believe the sounds will make
them better people or make life better.
You know what dude?
You want such a great roll to your right.
Wrote that fucking sentence. Yeah. Oh,
what do they believe the sounds will make
them better people or make their life
better? I found it most
annoying and of in invasive,
right? I find it. Oh Jesus Christ, I'm
never drinking on the podcast again.
Go fuck yourselves. All right. What
is wrong with people? Where am I?
I find it the most annoying and evasive
thing. I am forced to listen to,
even with closed windows,
but they're so peaceful.
Um,
if you fucking like the sound,
why don't you put them up inside your
home and have the fucking fan going
in any way? What gives anybody the right
to push their taste on others? Dude,
I totally agree. It's like if you're
going to make smokers smoke outside,
then you want to make these fucking wind
chime. People take that shit indoors.
I can't tell you how annoying that is.
It's uh,
you know what's annoying about it is it's
an annoying sound that's trying to be
fucking spiritual. That's what
kills me. It's even, um, it's,
it's more annoying than just the loud,
annoying sound that's fucking annoying.
Cause at least the loud annoying sound
has to fucking courage to be annoying.
Those fucking things. They
actually, they're there,
they're there. You know what,
when I go on youtube and just get some
fucking wind chime sounds for all you've
done concert out there who do yoga,
you know and actually think that these
fucking things sound good. Here we go.
Wind fucking Shaimes youtube.
Let's see what we got. Here we go.
Yeah, cause somebody fucking loves
him so much. They put up a video.
Here we go for all you cops
out there. Here it is. Okay.
[inaudible]
I got to.
Those are nice.
[inaudible]
this isn't fair. This guy's got fuck. He's
got the professional grade level ones.
He thinks look like the
exhaust on a Goddamn. Okay.
Oh, that's giant wind change.
All right. I just learned
something. I don't mind. Giant
wind chimes. Oh, here's one.
Here's one of these little douchey ones
you get at a fucking hardware store.
Yeah, just typical youtube. You
just can't put wind chimes, Elliot.
Beautiful wind shame.
Is this the county and one
there it is.
[inaudible].
You know what the great thing is,
is they're made out of metal.
So when you rip them off,
you have a fucking blunt object to beat
your neighbor to death with [inaudible].
That's what you do.
And then you dip it in and fucking
peroxide or bleach and you hook it back up
again.
Let those a and e cons.
Figure out that murder a
man murdered on his porch.
You know, somehow they'd
find, you know, and a fucking,
I don't know,
an eighth of an inch of his face
imprint on that fucking wind chime.
If you ever watched those a and e things,
how they catch people, it's, it's like,
it's not even fucking fair.
You ever see the one as I take another
healthy way. I got news for you.
I'm having another beer.
This might be the new thing.
I might do this shit Thursday night.
Take a night off from stand up.
Tell my chick to hit the fucking bricks.
Is there anything better than
drinking your own goddamn house?
It just makes you want to start screaming
about this shit you own. You know
I paid for this shit.
You hear that old man downstairs,
I'm going to get louder and
he's going to come up here.
That would be the ultimate podcast. You
know what the thing about old people is,
you always have to worry that they
are a fucking, like they, they,
they fought in a fucking war
cause I never had, I never have.
So I have total respect
for fucking veterans in the
fact that they still got it
in him.
You know,
that would be insane one night if I
actually just totally pissed him off.
And he really did fight in the Korean
War and he just fucking through whatever
that fucking thing is
you throw up when you,
when you're gonna climb up the rope on
the side of the building, you know, that,
that,
that fucking land fish hook thing
throws it up there and just climbs up.
Comes over my railing as I'm sitting
here doing this podcast. Half in the bag.
Yeah. He's got a kitchen knife between
his teeth, like a fucking pirate.
What would I do?
I've probably taken 12 karate classes
in my life and they've all been like,
you know, six years apart. Yeah.
Fucking guy coming in
and fully me. Yeah, know
I don't fucking know. I just sat back
and I just lost the screen here. Yeah.
So whatever wind chimes are
fucking overrated. They really are.
But I gotta tell you, if you get
the giant ones, the giant ones,
a nice listen to the giant ones that
Jason wants to have a nice tone to him.
It's a little deeper.
I think I figured it out.
Come on man.
You gotta admit that's not bad.
If you let go of the anger you childhood,
right? Let go of anger for a second.
Si sound of a ship in the background.
Uh,
okay.
The ocean coming up on the beach.
You have get to that point right when
you're going to get relaxed and let go and
then you get so fucking scared.
You get right back into the anger and
then you want to punch somebody in fucking
yoga pants. Um, all right, I have
enough with the fucking windshield here.
That was really painting a picture there.
I fucking Michael Winslow here.
I think it's time for more booze.
What do you guys think?
How about a nice healthy sip.
Yeah.
Ah, God dammit. It's fucking delicious.
He poor bastards and Owen. Oh,
and a you poor bastards in Aa.
And that was one good thing about
the trip. Uh, when I went back,
it's actually got to do open Anthony and
I'm going to do it again. Um, next week,
probably again the Tuesday again,
I'm on the exact same flight
back to Los Angeles. I did it,
the opiod Anthony show this past Tuesday,
popped in there for like an hour.
I had a good fucking time.
Didn't get a chance to argue with Anthony,
but you know, it's still good
to say them as adorable as ever.
All right, let's uh,
let's plow ahead here. Um,
let's get to some more fucking
overrated shit. Um, overrated.
Super expensive TVS.
Who the fuck needs to
spend two grand on a TV?
I know the super clear, et Cetera,
but it's not like it's, it's,
I'm a huge jump. My eight year
old, Sony still works great.
The picture is fine.
If I want to watch some great TV,
I'll just go to one of a hundred bars
in the city that have 80 of them slapped
on the walls.
Which another thing,
which is another thing that's overrated
cookie cutter bars with a million TVs
and zero atmosphere.
But I digress
you guys,
while you guys are fucking good writers
and I like how you said I digress rather
than me last week when I say,
but I digressed in the past tense because
I never use that expression animal
memorial on.
Um, dude, I have to totally
agree with you. In fact,
I would still have an
old school TV if I'm,
I didn't move from New York,
New York to La.
I was going to keep my old school one.
I had no problem watching the
game on the old school square TV.
It didn't bug me. You know, I don't
need to see that. The inside of shacks,
I don't need to see shacks. Fucking,
you know, knows Cartlidge. Ever.
When I first got HDTV,
I was watching a,
I was watching ESPN and like Stuart Scott
or one of those guys is doing it and
I'm like looking at his pores and I
could see actually a little bit of the
inside of his nose. Nose wasn't dirty or
nothing, but it was just, it's like, dude,
all I need is just to hear the scores.
I'll tell you know it's fucking overrated
too and I hope it flops like fucking
David Beckham in La are.
Here's one great overrated
is fucking Shit in three d.
All right,
Avatar in three day.
Who gives a fuck?
Some butterfly flying near
you face your goddamn ferry.
The fuck is wrong with you
and all these idiots who are going
to go out and buy three d TVs.
You dumb fucks if you buy a three D TV.
You know what she'll like?
You like those?
Do you like one of those dumb shits
who keeps buying the new razor blades?
Has any razor blade worked
better than the fucking,
all you needed was to one sucked too
was the shit three doesn't do underneath
your nose.
You've got to pinch your nose,
like you're in a barbershop
in the 19 fucking twenties,
getting a straight razor shave
during a fucking three stooges film.
And then it goes all the way up to four.
And then they knew they couldn't do
five or did they do five and now they're
trying to act like the blades or even
fucking sharper. It's all bullshit.
The worst thing that ever happened to me,
one time I was doing college of something,
I think I was in Florida and
it was the double whammy.
I had a toiletry,
a bag from tough crowd,
one of my favorite fucking shows to
do. Tough crowd with Colin Quinn. Um,
and one of the, one of the gift
bags they gave you was, was this,
this toiletry bag. It's a tough crowd
on it and shit, you know. And uh,
not only did I leave that for God
and in the bathroom, but my, uh,
my razor,
my twin bladed razor was in it
and they don't sell them anymore.
And ever since then I've had the
triple one and it just sucks. Hey,
if there's one whisker right in that,
that the skin between your
fucking nostrils, I can't get it.
I can't get it and I got to do all
these different fucking tricks.
I'll do it right now. You
just, I gotta like, you know,
make my nose look like that fucking
chicks knows in the Batman revenge movie.
Um, I bet she has no
problem. I was kind of mean.
Yeah. So you guys do me a
favor. All right. Don't buy
it. Don't buy three D TV's.
Don't fucking buy him. Okay. Two
dimensional football is still the shit.
Are you really going to sit there on
the couch with your friend wearing those
stupid fucking glasses?
So what?
[inaudible] balls can be in your face.
Come on.
You want to see it in three d?
Go to the fucking game.
I'll watch the TVS will be awesome.
The TVS will be awesome and
eventually I'll get them.
If you guys noticed what a fucking
hypocrite I am, I bought the Prius,
I defended it.
And slowly I'm going towards a challenger.
You know how fucking totally
into into conspiracy theory.
I'm actually still into that shit.
And I don't give a fuck.
Now I'm just sitting here in my
underwear doing a podcast and on Thursday
drinking a beer,
you know,
I quit fucking quit. You know what
I realized the other day too is a,
you don't have a gate.
You start talking shit.
When you get into conspiracy theory,
you actually think that like, you know,
you're a,
you're on to something dangerous and
people are gonna start watching you.
But the bottom line is,
is the second you recorded it and there's,
you know, I just look at what
Mel Gibson is going through,
what he's going through with the
recorded shit that he's fucking said.
I'm not saying I said
anything racist or anything,
but everything that I've done in the
podcast and last three fucking years,
I could never pull a Schwartzenegger.
Let's just fucking just like totally
get into fantasy here.
Let's pretend that I actually somehow
became a huge fucking movie star.
Did it for 20 years and then got sick
of it and decided to run for political
office.
You could pick any one of my podcast and
that would be the end of the campaign.
You know,
especially those ones early on when I
said con to every other fucking word,
I just, I go through phases. I
didn't, I got into golf for a minute.
I got into conspiracy theory for a minute.
I got into saying confirm
minute and I don't know,
it just all goes by the fucking wayside.
This is one of the reasons why I
can't sustain a fucking relationship,
although I've been able to sustain
this one. You know, I finally realized,
uh, I'm, I'm, I'm going to stop fucking
running like that fucking Eagle Song.
That's stupid song. Desperado you
know, I would like to do that.
Five.
We'd like to do a three stooges slapped
to everybody in the eagles is great of,
of musicians that they are those
cheese balls, songs that they wrote
days the Ratto.
Why don't you call to your
[inaudible] shut up Don Henley.
Just play the fucking drums.
Why don't you make a good fucking song?
This song's a class I wanted.
Whatever the fuck. Who am I kidding?
I'd love to be making the fucking
bank. Those guys are making, you know,
I'm going to warn you guys, bear when I
make some fucking money in this business,
I'm going to sell out like you've never
seen anybody sell out in your fucking
life. I don't know what I'm gonna
do, but I'm going to tap out.
I know I am. I'm going to buy a modest
house in the middle of fucking nowhere.
I was actually looking at property
in like Wyoming and Montana.
I'm getting into that shit.
Having a fucking ranch couple of fucking
Jakks goddamn pig that you can boot in
the ass when your well water
isn't coming up that day.
Fucking shit ain't working.
Thing running over the hill.
Who's going to report you? You're
out there by yourself, dude.
You live in fucking Wyoming or Montana.
You get yourself a spread.
You know you might as,
it's like you have your own country
just walk around naked on your property.
Nothing but you and your fucking, it's
just shooting shit slowly go and crazy
best friends with like a pheasant.
You know,
I fucking love it.
Learn how to grow fucking
vegetables and shit.
You want to stand that I'll
fucking awesome. That would be,
because I'll still do standup.
Just listen to this.
This is the fucking dream that for
some reason this week I'm totally into,
I'm going to live like that.
And then every other week I get to leave
the Ponderosa and then I fly into a
fucking metropolis.
Right. Get the, you know,
hang out with everybody who's living
on top of one another. You know,
soak up that vibe for a minute. Hang
an extra day, go to a football game,
you know, eat somebody barbecue
that they claim is the greatest,
but it's always some dried out fucking
ribs and chicken with some sweet sauce.
The sauce always tastes the best. The
MITO, we sucks. You know, once again,
I had some more smoked fucking barbecue
when I or whatever the hell it is.
I always eat it.
I always believe like this is going to
be the one that's gonna make me like it.
Um, anyways. Nah Dude,
I would love to fucking do that shit.
I don't know if I could do it.
I don't know if I could live way
out in the middle of nowhere.
Um, but I'm telling you
man, that, that really the,
the longer I'm in this business and the
longer I'm on flights and I'm sitting
next to people with fucking flakes behind
their ears and they're getting up and
they're walking to the bathroom without
their fucking shoes on and I'm listening
to the male stewardess on the Mike,
we have a very full flight,
you know, if he can feet, if he can feed,
if they can fit in the
seat and friendly view,
please be Korean style and people
on the flight. And they never are.
They never are.
People up there just stick and shit.
They could easily fit in front of the
seat in front of them. And I swear to God,
and he'll be like,
John Denver,
I learn how to fly a plane and by some
experimental fucking thing and crashing
into the side of a mountain.
That's the thing though. That's,
that's the ultimate right there
that the, I'll tell you right now,
if you guys want to know what
it's like to do the fucking road,
and I'm telling you right now,
I know salesman and people with
corporate jobs who have to fly around the
country.
What you do after a while as
you fantasize about the way,
um,
you want to do the road.
If you could do the fucking
road and I would love it.
I don't know if I could live in fucking
in the middle of nowhere like that, but,
well, let's just say I could,
so this would be the deal.
I live in the middle of nowhere
on the fucking Ponderosa, right?
Woodburn and stove.
It's,
it's like it's a fucking log cabin,
but you still got the flat screen.
I'll build a fucking ice rink out
back for the kids that I don't have,
you know,
have like four fucking dogs
because who gives a shit?
You buy a mansion for
like 1200 bucks out there.
Have like four fucking dogs.
Keep I get Guy Cleo.
I'll get a fucking, okay. Pitbull boxer,
a fucking bulldog.
And then what else I get a month.
I mean a bloodhound.
Yeah,
something that likes to howl but
also likes to lay around, you know,
do my MTV cribs around and
have a bunch of fucking cars.
I'll have the baddest of the
Lamborghini, the Ferrari, the Porsche,
and the fucking dodge challenger.
A dog's right.
Line them up in my fucking dirt driveway,
you know, and then down the street
somehow I'd have my own pride. This is,
this is the ultimate, right? I'd
have my own fucking private jet. Oh.
Meanwhile the business is also
sending me fucking movie scripts.
Just offer me begging me, begging
me, not only to be in the movie,
but all I got to be is like the fucking
six to lead. And when I show up,
they shoot all my shit. You
know, you have me for five days,
shoot all my fucking scenes and I'm that
guy who was in the movie like fucking
three, four times, but kills it. So I
keep my career going. This is the dream.
Then I live in the middle of nowhere.
I fucking make my fucking, ah,
got my garden in the back.
Fresh vegetables,
got chicken coop every once in awhile.
Who wants a fucking Burrito?
Hang on a second. I'm going to
go wring the neck of something.
You grab it and you're fucking
by the neck is how you do it.
You grabbed by the neck and then you
spin their fucking body around and that's
it.
All right.
You have your oldest son named John
Boy and you haven't plucked the shit.
You stick it in the set it and forget it.
You kept it as a joke,
as a reminder of civilization.
You fucking eat that way.
And then whenever I got a Gig, I go
down the fucking street down the street,
whatever,
rural road number 47 and there's the,
and there's a fucking airport and I
got my own jet and pilots on call,
right?
And in the back of the plane,
that's just a big goddamn bed
with a huge fucking seatbelt.
And they fucking knocked me out.
If it's a long flight, if it isn't,
I just sit there shooting the shit
with the pilots and that's what I do.
And then I fly in, I do the Gig, and
then I fucking go to a sporting event.
Then I fly back.
That's my fucking dream.
That's my dream of how I'd like to do
the road. How do you like that? Huh?
Boozes got on the podcast,
isn't it?
I hope I'm not going to listen back to
this when I'm not buzzed and think that
this is fucked up, but that's
something I would like to do. Um,
but I gotta be honest with you,
I don't think that I could
live in a Wyoming or Montana.
Um,
I do think that I could live,
where can I live?
I
could live in parts of Pennsylvania,
Connecticut,
upstate New York,
parts of northern New Jersey.
Uh,
maybe western Massachusetts.
I Dunno.
Maybe Northern California.
We get up there and they got some
redwoods and shit. I don't know.
That's fucked up, man. It's scary. You
want to do something fucked up? Go, uh,
go on a, go on Google maps and just, uh,
just look at Montana and then just pick,
um,
pick a town and then hit
satellite and then just, you know,
dropped that little man and then just
go down a fucking street and you'll see
what it's like out there.
You know?
And if you don't hear a banjo music in
on a fucking human being, it's scary.
I'd love to go out there, man. I
want to check it out. You know,
just see what the fuck
is going on up there.
Actually know a guy who has
a gig out in fucking Montana.
I've actually was thinking about
doing it just cause I've never been,
never been out that way. Um, all right,
let's get on with the overrated underrated
now or continue with it. I should say.
Uh, do overrated. The word.
Oh, I this one. Overrated.
The use of the word countless.
I hear it on the news all the time.
This tragedy has left countless
numbers of people homeless.
That's bullshit. I think there are
like six or 7 billion people on earth.
I know the numeric system works.
I can count to 7 billion. Hell,
I could count to 7
trillion given enough time.
I'm not saying the tragedies
that happen aren't bad,
but trying to jack up the fear quotion
by making it sound like the number of
people affected is just too
big to comprehend is bullshit.
I liked that. I never noticed that.
Leaving countless people homeless.
Uh, what do you mean by the
actually 1,247? Well, you know what?
I think I could count that high.
Are you saying that you don't care
about the homeless? No. You dumb cunt.
I'm saying that I can count that
high. So it's not countless. 1200 is,
it's countable leaving countable people
homeless. This guy is absolutely right.
Or this woman, whoever wrote
it in absolutely fucking right.
You are absolutely fucking correct
on that one. Uh, underrated, uh,
animated shows on TV today.
The Simpsons and family guy
are legitimately well done
shows and south park to a
lesser degree. Dude, I think
South Park is still the best.
I'd go South Park,
the Simpsons and then the family guy.
South Park has the best social commentary
on TV. But I have to tell you this,
I don't watch that show. What the
fuck is it? I always mean to watch it.
It comes on Sunday night. The, um,
I had, fuck do I describe
it? It's the, uh,
African American one. There
we go. Come on. You know it.
I don't know what it is,
but I heard that one is the shit.
What the fuck is the name of it? I can't
remember. I heard that one's awesome.
I got to get into watching that. I always
say I'm going to, and then I never do.
And there's also a billboard I've seen
on sunset boulevard out here for that
show. Children's hospital.
It looks creepy as hell.
And it's on a adult swim.
That's what I'm trying to say.
Adult swim is what that other, the
Boondocks, right? Is that the name of it?
And then there's the, um, I heard
that children's hospital is great.
I want to check that one out too.
Alright. Ah, what are we doing? Well,
where are we going? Ah, they, AH, okay.
Um, cartoons that they have good writing,
good plot points and legitimate
social commentary. Totally
agree. And all of that.
This is what pisses me off though.
I can tell you that the number of times
that someone will ask me what I've
watched on television, I will give
them the plot of a Simpsons episode,
not mentioning any names,
um,
or the fact that it's a cartoon and they
will tell me how funny they think it is.
But then when I tell them it's
the Simpsons of the family guy,
it's a Simpson or a family guy episode.
All of a sudden they turn their noses
up and say that they're adults and they
don't watch cartoons anymore.
What the fuck is up with that?
A funny show is a funny show,
Dude. I couldn't agree with more.
I couldn't agree with you more.
Let me take the last fucking Swig
here and I'm going to, uh, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna Finish this thing off and
I'm going to finish up the podcast. Um,
here's something that I have learned
on a, on the podcast. Hang on a second.
Here we go. Let me get a little
more, a little more happy juice here.
Oh God. Damn. That's fucking perfect. Um,
anyways, oh, by the way, uh,
I've been watching a lot of
the old Jackie Gleason. Um,
I used to watch him when I was a kid
and I never really noticed how many the,
the older shows,
it was weird.
I don't know what it was
because I came up in the 70s.
You have to understand that a lot of
the original shows weren't filmed,
so there was no syndication. That was
the brilliance of Ricky Ricardo there.
Uh, what's his face there? Ricky
Ricardo was his character name. Um,
Desi Arnaz that he actually
had the brilliance to film.
I love you. I love Lucy and get
the rights for the old episodes.
Like nobody in the business for saw
the money in reruns and they just,
they signed off and just gave him to
them basically for fucking nothing.
So anyways, there wasn't a lot of reruns.
Certainly from the 1950s. There's,
you know, a lot of those live shows, they
just went live and that was it. But, um,
so like, what am I trying to say? And
actually television was this how old I am?
Television for the most
as far as the golden
age of television,
right up was only 20 years old
and there was only three networks.
So you basically got the best of the best.
And I used to watch like
the Jackie Gleason show,
they used to show reruns
of the Dean Martin show.
I know this makes me sound like
I'm older than fucking dirt,
but they used to play it. They used
to play all that shit, three stooges,
all that type of shit.
And I used to watch the Jackie Gleason
show and he had this character,
Reginald van Gleason.
And um,
I don't know the character,
he just had this little broom mustache.
And before he would say anything
he would of sort of hum. Hmm.
And then say whatever he said.
And I watched one the other
day where he was playing, uh,
he's trying to solve a murder mystery
and he comes walking in on this couple is
a dead body in there. And, uh,
but before we start questioning
them about the murder,
he actually sees a wet bar.
So he just puts his index finger up.
This is why I'd love to buy
Jackie Gleason was how, um,
without saying anything, he freaking
could go for like, you know,
minutes on ends without saying anything
and just have you die in laughing.
And He, and, and he never rehearsed
either. And he just fought.
He puts his finger up and after he sees
the bar and he walks over to the wet bar
and he does all this exaggerated
shit of making the drink,
but before he walks in
with a second, he's, I'm to
explaining this wrong, whatever,
he comes walking over to the bar, the
second he sees it, he just goes, hmm,
booze. Right? And it gets this
huge fucking laugh. I don't know.
I don't know. The, I just
loved that old school shit.
We're fucking drinking and having
a drinking problem is funny.
This guy,
this is a dead body in the room and
he's gonna make himself a drink first.
He obviously has his preop priorities
around a fucking whack and nobody gives a
shit. So whatever. But anyways, this last
week of this podcast, I really learned,
man, uh, how to do, uh,
if I ever want to do a fucking radio show,
there's three,
there's three topics that get me the
most email responses of either I totally
agree with you or you're fucking
annoying the shit out of me.
And they are politics,
sports and uh,
and Jesus or any sort of religion.
If I go off on any of
those like, uh, you know,
trashing the fucking, uh, Lebron on
trusting what did I do a few weeks ago,
I trashed, um, New York and the Knicks.
I got all these fucking emails
from Knicks fans, you know,
last week I trashed the fucking, uh,
I didn't think I trashed the Lakers.
I thought I was just talking
about Kobe versus um, um, Jordan,
but are all these fucking Laker fans,
just fucking writing in
writing and capital letters,
flipping the fuck out.
And uh, I don't know.
This podcast has been
very in like the end,
like that level where it's like a,
if I ever do a fucking radio show,
which I don't think I will,
I like doing this shit better and I
always felt when I did on informed,
when we were actually able
to do episodes of that,
I always felt the collars
slowed down the show, you know,
and it was so many people just
fucking with you or whatever.
But if I ever get a situation,
I have to do a radio show
and I want to get collars,
those are the three fucking magic topics
that just get people flipping the fuck
out. I guess the fourth would be a fee
if you trash one of the sexist, you know,
I don't know what the
fuck I'm saying here.
I'm just enjoying the nice buzz of one
fucking beer. That's a great thing to do.
Drink up,
drink a 16 ounce,
really good beer on an empty
fucking stomach, you know,
and do a God damn podcast and tell me
you're not proud to be a fucking American.
All right, that's it. Okay.
I think we had a little bit of something
for everybody here. Wind chimes,
booze reminiscing, telling you my, my,
my dreams of how I want to
live in the fucking future.
I guess none of which included having
a spouse or children. Fucking creepy.
Is that a,
that's it.
That's the podcast here that I
did it on a Thursday and I'm,
hopefully I'm going to try and
do Letterman again next week.
My set is more than ready to go and I'll
try to give you the heads up this time
if I have fight, get bumped up, but
whatever, it's actually, I actually,
I'm kind of psyched that I got bumped
because there's nothing cooler than going
to the Ed Sullivan Theater. It's just a
shit. And he just, he come up beforehand,
they show you where your mark is,
and as much as it's showing you where your
market is, you sit sitting there, God,
Jesus Christ, the fucking Beatles
were here, the stones were here,
the doors came as where the doors came
out, and then, and, and Jim Morrison,
whatever the fuck he wasn't supposed
to say. He said, it's incredible.
It's an incredible,
uh,
I'd say it's one of the few things left
in show business that is still as big as
show business was back in the day before
it all got splintered into like 400,
400 different, uh,
channels. Um, so whatever,
all you young comics out there who never
done let them, and I'm telling you,
it's not gonna fucking disappoint
you. It's a, it's a huge thrill.
And this is my fifth time doing it.
I'm beyond excited and I'm really
hoping I get to get on this weekend. Ah,
that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I hope all you guys
enjoyed it and we'll talk,
see you next week. Okay. Take it easy.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].